20:19 has been quite the year so we're
working on a lot of stuff right now a
lot of head down out of computer I'm
pausing for a second because I want to
talk about my top five favorite places
on earth in no particular order and
based on no objective criteria other
than I just really like to travel it to
these places and I want to tell you
about them and explain why I like them
because people ask me all the time so
here I am answering your question number
one is Taiwan which is secretly tied
with Hong Kong but I had to choose one
here and Taiwan's from fresher in my
brain and so I chose Taiwan I went to
Taiwan with is and the boys to shoot is
his show called traveling repeat which
by the way is really good and you should
just go watch it on the youtubes meter
channel anyway what I loved about Taiwan
is that it felt like this unique fusion
of cultures Taiwan is at its root a part
of China in history and culture but due
to years of Japanese occupation there's
also some very Japanese vibes to it in
the architecture in the food and in just
the general culture of the place
definitely has some Japanese influence
but Taiwan has its own very unique
particular culture that it's not totally
Chinese and is not totally Japanese it
is Taiwanese a big part of that culture
is food and a big part of that food
culture is street food
[Music]
but of all the stuff we did in Taiwan my
absolute favorite part was this you
don't have to go very far outside the
big cities to find these misty mountains
they're like jungly and beautiful and
they go forever and they're abundant you
don't run into other people it's not
like there's just one tourist
destination we drove through these
mountains shooting is a show from tea
plantations to Hot Springs to noodle
making operations it was so nice and
peaceful and it was like lightly
drizzling the whole time because we were
like in a cloud there's not to make our
own tea which was just a lifelong dream
of mine it's wonderful like I said I'm
incredibly torn between Taiwan which we
just went to this year and Hong Kong
where we were last year which are very
different and unique and then right but
have a lot of these similar qualities
which is hyper urban culture street food
mixed with like nature that's like woven
into it all and both places are amazing
number two southern Utah every time I go
to Southern Utah I forget how amazing it
is
you drive just a few hours south of Salt
Lake and you suddenly feel like you're
entering a different planet the geology
the color of the rocks even the way the
light feels is just different what I
love about southern Utah is the
abundance of nature you don't have to go
to the big national parks like Zion in
order to see some incredible incredible
stuff you can see it on the side of the
road you can go down random gravel roads
and end up in really beautiful spots it
reminded me that even though I like to
chase adventures in other countries
sometimes here at home there are some of
the most kind of exotic and wild things
waiting so southern Utah is my number
two here number three is a little town
in Belgium club livin lovin is right
outside of Brussels and while Brussels
and Bruges and Antwerp tend to get the
most kind of attention from visitors
lovin is a diamond in the rough
[Music]
most people don't really know about it
or think about it I only discovered this
place because I was speaking at like a
conference that was there for like a
bunch of like Flemish speaking
journalists Leuven is like effectively
just like a big village that at least
the inner city feels just so quiet and
approachable while still having some
bustle and buzz that gives it charm
there are big old traditional European
squares filled with amazing restaurants
and bars
the place is bikable there are amazing
forests and parks you're right on the
edge of a huge forest at part of Belgium
and so you are just surrounded by really
beautiful nature we were biking in love
in one evening and stumbled upon this
really old structure that is now I think
a part of the University
but for real what we just stumble on
Lovan just felt like a peaceful
wonderful place full of interesting
culture and sights and just a
well-designed
town that was definitely worth a visit
I'm really glad we found a live-in okay
so number four on this list is southern
Iceland I went there originally not as a
tourist but as a journalist I was there
interviewing the prime minister of
Iceland for the Netflix episode of
explained which is Fox's show that I did
on the gender pay gap so we were
interviewing the prime minister and I
got to enter Iceland not from kind of
the tourists door but from like the I'm
there trying to understand the culture
and talking to people members of civil
society and the government and the Prime
Minister and like having those types of
conversations and so in that process I
gained this appreciation for Iceland not
just as a beautiful place but as like a
hyper progressive country that is doing
really amazing interesting policy
experiments and kind of leading the
charge on a lot of these social issues
fast forward a little bit earlier this
year is and I went to Iceland for just a
few days I feel like I should feel like
I should draw the graph on this beach
yeah to go as tourists I surprised her
for her birthday
we found cheap tickets and we ended up
in Iceland in January and everyone told
us don't go to Iceland in January
because it's gonna be dark and it's
gonna be cold and you won't see anything
and I was like but the tickets are so
cheap so I couldn't help myself
turns out going to Iceland in January is
sweet because there's no one there and
yeah it's dark some of the time but like
you still get from like 10 a.m. to 4
p.m. of like this beautiful sunset
sunrise light that is just really wild
[Music]
all of this contributes to Iceland just
feeling like a different planet so we
spent four days touring the south of the
country which is a very well trodden
very popular and touristy part of the
country but even still we felt secluded
and alone a lot of the time Iceland has
obviously gotten tons and tons of
tourism in fact I made this chart for an
earlier video that shows how many
tourists go to Iceland now and for some
of us me included that can be a turn-off
like Oh Iceland is cool I'm not gonna go
to Iceland I will say there's a reason
there is a reason why this place is a
destination there are some really
negative ramifications for the local
nature and culture of all of this
tourism which is a problem in of itself
but if you're a respectful visitor and
you want to go engage with this
beautiful beautiful place you definitely
should they might be trending but it's
sweet
[Music]
whoa where did you come from yeah I need
to I needed a change of space okay well
I'm on number four southern Iceland did
you like southern Iceland I should go
back anyway number five and the last one
on this list which by no means is
comprehensive or objective as I've said
but number five of the places I love
most in the world right now is Porto
Portugal
[Music]
so let's be clear about one thing all of
Portugal is amazing it is a small
country that has an extreme diversity of
landscapes and histories Portugal's
great at the very top of Portugal is
this old old old city centre in fact
it's like one of the oldest population
centres in all of Europe
a port though or in Portuguese like o
port though I don't know for me Porto
didn't have any specific one site or
attraction that made it worth visiting
it was just the general energy and vibe
of the city that just like stole my
heart the place is on this hill with
this big bridge going across this river
it's one of the older bridges in Europe
and it just has this unique
double-decker design you can get on a
boat and see all of the bridges the
architecture and the design of the city
and the food and the culture like it
just all felt very enlightening for me
as someone who wasn't super aware of
Portuguese culture and Porto felt like a
good representation of at least some of
this history of this country yeah
Porto was good okay I know I said five
but I like I'm having a bit of a hard
time because there's one more that I
can't not mention on this list which may
be actually my favorite one and I don't
know why I'm mentioning it last but here
it is the Jungfrau region of Switzerland
[Applause]
[Music]
this place had been on my mind for a
decade probably the most popular part of
the Swiss Alps and so a lot of people go
there kind of is their first time but
again like Iceland that didn't cheapen
it for me
you realize that these valleys these
mountains these trains and cable cars
and funiculars are seen as a world
destination for a reason what I love
about it is that the Swiss have mastered
mobility movement moving around really
really rugged terrain in like the
smoothest most efficient way so they
have these big mountains and they've
just built all of this infrastructure to
allow you to get around you by the
Jungfrau paths and you can get on all of
these transportation mechanisms and just
weave around these valleys and mountains
we happened to have gone at the very end
of the season we went mid-october and
off and just merrily and I've seen
just risky because things are closing
but it also means an empty drain
and D restaurants not mad about it it's
risky to because the weather could be
yeah we got amazing weather somehow and
there was plenty of stuff open and we
just lucked out there was no one there I
really felt like we had the whole place
to ourselves which is rare in the entire
region we like to kind of take those
Gamble's with this offseason stuff look
like right on the threshold whence the
weather supposed to get bad and would go
anyway and the lodging is usually
cheaper less people sometimes we get hit
with a lot of bad weather sometimes we
don't and in this case we didn't and it
was amazing and it chopped up as
probably one of my favorite trips of all
time is actually made an entire like
guide of what exactly we did day by day
in the Jungfrau region which I will link
below so that's my list of five really
six places that have made the list of my
favorite places in the world right now
this list is always changing I'm always
changing myself but the reason I'm
thinking about this right now the reason
I'm talking about this is kind of a
theme that's coming up a lot here on
this channel but also like in my own
life which is I'm trying to think about
travel not just as the status quo part
of my life that is my job I got into
this because of the thrill of going and
learning about new places and I want my
travel which to me is a privilege is
something that is something that humans
have not been able to do for thousands
of years and now we have the technology
to be able to move around the world so
seamlessly like I want when I do jet off
on an airplane across the world like
that I do it intentionally and I do it
to add value to my life and that of my
family we're learning that we're
connecting that we are going as more
enlightened and travelers and so I'm
checking in a lot with my motives and my
kind of approach to travel recently
which is why I'm talking about it all
the time I want to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this video today Skillshare
is this amazing platform and community
where you can go learn a bunch of stuff
from creative skills to entrepreneurial
skills to passion based skills to
whatever skill you want to
Skillshare probably has something for
you on Skillshare you pay a monthly
subscription fee and then you get
unlimited access to all of these
tutorials there's one course in
particular that I can recommend from
Skillshare which is this one about
mastering illustrator illustrator the
Adobe software as someone who does
animation and video you might be like
why are you into illustrator because
illustrator has changed my life as a
designer and someone who makes animation
if I didn't have a fluency in
illustrator I wouldn't be able to do
what I do with animation in After
Effects learning illustrator its kind of
not the obvious choice but I can tell
you it is a smart choice
so skill shares got that great course
among thousands of others because
they're sponsoring this video you can go
to the link in the descriptions which is
the link with my name at the back of it
so if you click that link you will go
and get two months of free Skillshare I
mean you won't pay for two months and
you can decide if you like it if it fits
within your world if you're interested I
think after the trial ends it's like 10
bucks a month if you do the annual
pricing so it's pretty darn cheap for
what you're getting I'm a big believer
in online learning obviously all of my
skills came from online learning and so
I have a soft spot in my heart for this
kind of stuff so thank you Skillshare
for sponsoring this video thank you all
for watching and I'll see you next time